INTRO:
Over the past several years, Apple has dominated
the top of the fortune 500.
From being the first company to reach a $1
trillion valuation to being the first company
to reach a $3 trillion valuation.
Much of this success is often credited to
Steve Jobs which makes sense given that he
was the visionary who gave Apple some of its
most iconic ideas and attributes.
With that being said though, Tim Cook has
now been the CEO of Apple for over 10 years,
and during that time period, he’s had some
of the best execution and least drama of any
silicon valley executive.
From overseeing Apple foray’s into services
to leading new product launches such as the
Apple Watch, Airpods, the M1 chip, and potentially
soon the Apple Car and Apple Glasses.
There’s no doubt that Apple wouldn’t be
what they are today without Tim Cook, but
it seems like Cook’s journey at the top
is nearly coming to an end.
Rumors suggest that Cook is looking into a
succession plan and that he’ll retire after
he oversees the launch of one more major product
category.
Considering this, I thought it would be a
great time to look back at Cook’s past and
analyze how he became the CEO of Apple.
PRE APPLE:
Taking a look back, Tim’s story dates back
to November 1, 1960 to a small town in Alabama
called Mobile.
He grew up with two brothers named Gerald
and Michael in a pretty average American household.
Tim’s father, Donald, worked at a shipyard
while his mother, Geraldine, worked at a pharmacy.
It seems that his parents were strong Christians
as Tim would be baptized as a kid.
Anyway, Tim would end up attending Robertsdale
High School where he quickly became a star
student.
He graduated rank 2 in his class and he would
enroll in a local state college called Auburn
University.
While Tim always wanted to work at a computer
company, it doesn’t seem like he wanted
to be a programmer or a tech person per se.
It seems like he was always more interested
in the operations side of companies, and appropriately,
he majored in industrial engineering.
One of his first jobs after graduation was
at IBM where he mainly worked on their supply
chain.
While working at IBM, Tim also secured an
MBA from Duke University in 1988.
This allowed him to climb the corporate ladder
even quicker, and Tim soon became the North
American fulfillment director at IBM.
Despite this rapid progress though, Tim decided
to leave IBM after 12 years at the company.
In 1994, Tim was hired as the COO of a small
computer retailer named Intelligent Electronics.
He worked here for the next 3 years before
jumping over to Compaq Computer Corporation
as vice president.
Around this time, Apple was doing extremely
bad.
Revenue was diving off a cliff and the company
was on the verge of bankruptcy.
Meanwhile, Steve Jobs had been away from the
company for over a decade.
It wasn’t until Apple agreed to acquire
NEXT Software that Steve would return to Apple.
Originally, Steve was just supposed to be
a temporary CEO, but it quickly became clear
that no one else was better for the role especially
given the circumstances.
As Steve assembled a new executive team to
hopefully revive Apple, one of the people
he invited to join the company was of course
Tim Cook.
At first, Tim wasn’t sure if he was actually
going to join Apple, but one thing he was
sure of was that he would at least meet with
Steve Jobs.
Like many of us, Tim himself was a massive
fan of Steve who he thought was a creative
genius.
But, at the meeting, Steve talked to Tim about
his vision for what would eventually become
the iMac.
And after hearing Steve describe his vision,
Tim knew that he was gonna do it.
When Tim shared this news with his friends
and family, they all thought that he was crazy.
To give up an executive role at an established
computer company in order to join one that
was nearly extinct was completely irrational.
Tim admits that there’s no way to logically
justify his actions.
But, with that being said, Tim also knew that
working with Steve was a once in a lifetime
opportunity.
So, Tim listened to his gut and joined Apple
in 1998.
SUPPLY CHAIN WIZARD:
Despite joining a company that’s known for
their beautiful products and UI, Tim never
really worked on either of these aspects.
He knew that his expertise was within the
supply chain, and that’s where he focused
his efforts as senior vice president of worldwide
operations.
Tim’s first order of business was purging
Apple’s existing supply chain to reduce
complexity.
Tim slashed the number of supply chain vendors
from over a 100 down to just 24.
He also reduced the number of warehouses by
half, and he started shifting Apple towards
contract manufacturing.
Contract manufacturing is basically when you
hire third party companies to handle various
parts of the production and assembly process
like TSMC and Foxconn.
These companies also work with dozens of other
tech companies which allows them to reach
extraordinary economies of scale.
Aside from cleaning up the supply chain, Tim
spent a lot of his effort on inventory management.
One of the crown jewels of Apple’s supply
chain is just in time or JIT manufacturing,
and its roots can be traced back to Tim.
JIT manufacturing is the idea of eliminating
inventory.
In an ideal JIT implementation, stores would
carry absolutely no inventory.
This isn’t to say that you can’t go to
the store and buy the given product.
If you were to go to the store, the product
should ideally arrive at the store seconds
before you buy it.
Obviously, this isn’t very realistic, but
Tim was able to leverage JIT to reduce Apple’s
inventory from weeks of inventory to less
than 5 days worth of inventory.
This might not sound like a big deal, but
if you’ve ever run a business, and especially
a small business, you know that storing and
managing inventory is extremely expensive.
Take the iPhone for example.
Apple stopped releasing unit sales numbers
for the iPhone years ago, but let’s just
assume that it's 100 million units per year.
And let’s also assume that each iPhone costs
Apple $500 from their end.
If Apple were to store 5 weeks worth of inventory,
they would have to sink $5 billion into inventory.
If they only had to store 5 days worth of
inventory though, they would only have to
sink $685 million into inventory.
Again, this doesn’t really matter that much
today as they have plenty of cash.
But, back in the early 2000s, this was crucial
to cutting costs.
And with the help of contract and JIT manufacturing
which reduced costs and the help of the iMac
and the iPod which increased revenue, Apple
was finally able to regain profitability.
This allowed Steve to focus on the iPhone
which was of course a massive success, but
all was not good.
Steve was diagnosed with pancreatic cancer
which made it rather difficult for him to
juggle Apple and his personal health.
At one point, Steve actually needed a liver
transplant, and some sources suggest that
Tim offered to donate a portion of his liver,
but Steve declined the offer.
While Steve declined Tim’s offer, as Steve’s
health continued to decline, he delegated
more and more tasks to Tim until Tim was eventually
made interim CEO in 2009.
Steve would come back later that year, but
in early 2011, he would take another medical
leave of absence before he eventually resigned
in August of 2011 which made Tim Cook the
permanent CEO.
TIM’S LEGACY:
The first few years of Tim’s leadership
were rather easy given that iPhone adoption
was still yet to peak.
There were also plenty of new obvious features
to introduce like touch ID and a larger screen.
But, iPhone sales would eventually not only
peak but start to decline, and this is when
Tim’s skills as a CEO would really be put
to the test.
Tim addressed this decline with a two fold
solution with the first part being making
Apple a lifestyle company.
While Apple products have always been expensive,
it wasn’t till the last couple of years
that iPhones started getting a reputation
for being overpriced.
Now don’t get me wrong here, people have
criticized the price of the iPhone since the
day that it was launched, but I think the
price argument has shifted substantially.
Initially, the argument had less to do with
the device itself being overpriced and more
to do with it being too expensive for the
average person to buy.
Today, the argument has shifted more towards
the device itself being overpriced.
But ironically, entry level iPhones are actually
cheaper than ever before.
Apple keeps around older generations for longer
than ever before and the iPhone SE starts
at $429 which is cheaper than the original
iPhone.
I think this is all part of Tim’s strategy
to maintain Apple’s exclusive image.
If Apple’s presentations focused on how
their entry level phones are cheaper than
ever before, that would likely degrade Apple’s
image.
However, by focusing on the pro and pro max
versions that cost over $1000, Tim is brilliantly
able to get the media to paint Apple’s products
as exclusive and desirable.
I believe other overpriced products like the
Apple wheels and the Pro stand serve the same
purpose.
These products simply define Apple’s image
while Apple’s real revenue drivers are their
cheaper products.
Aside from crafting this genius balance between
brand image and practical products, Tim also
reduced Apple’s dependence on the iPhone
by embracing services.
iCloud, Apple Music, and Apple TV have all
been massive hits for Apple.
As of October 2020, Apple literally had 585
million paid subscribers.
Even if each of these subscribers only pay
Apple $5 per month, we’re talking about
nearly $3 billion in revenue per month and
$35 billion in revenue per year.
Considering this, it’s not surprising that
Apple’s revenue figures are higher than
ever before even though iPhone sales peaked
7 years ago.
Aside from these services providing Apple
with a great source of revenue, these services
also strengthen the Apple ecosystem and make
it harder and harder for users to leave.
And I think these three factors are what will
become Tim's legacy at Apple.
He defined Apple’s brand image, he significantly
reduced their dependence on iPhone sales,
and he crafted the Apple ecosystem.
TIM’S FINAL PRODUCT:
Looking forward, it looks like Tim is excited
to release one more product which is likely
either the Apple Glasses or the Apple Car.
The glasses would be a major step into the
AR market while the Apple Car would be a major
step into the EV and autonomy industries.
Either product could be a great sendoff product
for Tim, but if the final product is the car,
then Tim will likely have to stick around
for a lot longer.
After all, scaling EV production is no easy
task.
And given that Tim has publicly announced
that he probably won't be CEO in 10 years,
I’m inclined to believe that the last product
is likely the AR glasses.
Launching an EV vehicle would simply be a
much longer commitment.
Also, the AR glasses are much more aligned
with Apple’s other products.
A car is completely out of left field, and
Apple really has no prior experience in even
building a car.
They’ve already experienced several delays
and hurdles along the way, and I wouldn’t
be surprised if this project was scrapped
altogether.
So, the most likely scenario is that we see
Apple Glasses roll out in 2025 or 2026 followed
by Tim Cook resigning near the end of the
decade.
In terms of a successor, the fan favorite
seems to be Craig Federighi which is not surprising
given his charisma and stage presence.
But, experts feel that Craig is better suited
to continue leading software development as
opposed to becoming CEO.
I gotta say though, if Craig did become CEO,
Apple’s presentations would be quite fun,
almost like Steve Job’s presentations.
But, we’ll just have to wait and see.
In the meantime, Apple stock has already grown
10x under Tim’s leadership, so at this point,
for Tim, it’s just a matter of wrapping
up his journey with a bow and saying farewell.
When do you guys think Tim will retire and
who do you think will replace him?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re excited for
Tim’s last product.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.